the joe rogan experience speaking of
which
oh is it oj's on twitter i saw that [ __ ]
do you see that one guy who made a
parody video of his
welcome twitter world like he made this
weird dad
video it's so strangely
what's the word apocalyptic no
disingenuous
strangely disingenuous i thought it was
like deep fake like he's
acting again but he hasn't acted in
forever
and also maybe he's suffering
a little bit from the football injuries
because there's a struggle i'm i am
very sensitive to people
that have been hit in the head a lot of
times struggling to talk
yeah because i look for it i see it in
people i don't want to see it
and it's scary and we all talk about it
like people that work for the ufc
fighters trainers it's people who do
kickboxing we
everyone talks about seeing certain
folks yeah starting to slip and some
folks will start to talk about it about
themselves you know they're having a
problem yeah that's what i got
while i was listening to that it's like
hello twitter world
all right i didn't pick that soldier
simpson yeah i'm gonna but
i can dispel some of the bs the people
have been saying about um
about me with no accountability yeah
plus i'm gonna talk about sports and
politics it's like this weird acting
job that he did it's creepy man it was
weird
all that yeah it was a weird moment man
i
that's a cool that that that thing that
happens
to people who have like done shitty
things
where instead of just saying like yeah i
[ __ ] up i
can't say that you can't say yeah i
killed somebody right
well you can but if you do that
you're going to suddenly it'll be i
think for anybody who's done shitty
things
the moment you just say it you get to be
standing again on
the real ground like the real terrain
instead of like the
[ __ ] world you've been living in but
when you decide not to do that
then you do have this like it's like the
uncanny valley
like you have this like android quality
to you because
you're not reflecting reality you're
reflecting reality after you put
lipstick on it and
sunglasses and combed its hair yeah put
some perfume on it out of the nose job
got its ass got ass implants and that's
your [ __ ] reality is this super
plastic like someone who's been getting
plastic surgery for years and so
you're pretending that that's your
existence you see it man when
like people are getting sentenced for
killing people
and they're like the look on their
[ __ ] face is like
so confused because they have created
this
valley in between that person and the
person they are
and and you know it's they've split in
half essentially
and they can't deal with that's why so
many people have murdered people will
say
i wasn't there i don't remember it was a
dream
i didn't know i didn't do it and gacy
i i should be i should be sentenced for
running a funeral home without a license
he was saying when he was out of town
people were burying kid dead kid bodies
under his [ __ ] house
you know and he meant it he made it he
tricked himself enough really
absolutely because otherwise you have to
deal with the fact that you
are a murderer that you killed
[ __ ] you strangled [ __ ] kids that
you dress like a [ __ ] clown
you know and like killed kids like
it's so unpalatable to deal with that
[ __ ]
because you're just a crazy lunatic who
is out of control
so you'd rather make up a story usually
it's conspiratorial
somebody was like somebody's like hey
man you know where you can bury those
kid bodies
i think casey's out of town jesus christ
yeah man isn't that [ __ ] crazy it's
[ __ ] crazy
yeah jesus christ i know
and and that's the thing people have
always said about oj that
it's almost like he doesn't even believe
he did it now but the problem with that
is
there was a [ __ ] emoji that he
tweeted at this guy
you know he had a direct message with
this guy and he had like 16 knives
and he said he's going to cut him like
if that's true
if he really did send that if it's not
photoshopped that's not [ __ ]
can you imagine getting a dm from oj
because you made a parody video jesus
god
cause like while i can't guess what he
did was he put oj's video where he was
talking
and in the background he had someone
screaming help call the police help help
and so then oj sends him this direct
message allegedly
who knows if it really happened who
knows but if it did
dude i would [ __ ] i would like find a
cave somewhere i would want to move to
the himalayas i can't i couldn't deal
with it man
hello twitter world i'm just you know
because he could get you
like he could get you if you wanted to i
bet maybe yeah i mean
how much times you have left he's 71
years old after he dms you he disappears
you know people like we don't know where
he is
nor mcdonald tweeted out him hilarious
norm said
hey juice i just wanted to tell you that
through that video i know the golf
course that's behind you so i could
figure out where your house is and i
wouldn't do that but somebody else might
yeah that was hilarious nor macdonald's
so funny
he's the best i'm trying to get him to
do a podcast i was trying to get him and
adam eager to do a podcast
i don't know what he can do though while
he's got this his netflix deal
is i don't know where it's at i don't
know if he has a contract
but he should do a podcast it's a
goddamn national travesty
that he doesn't have a podcast he's so
[ __ ] funny
well isn't his show it's kind of like a
podcast like it has that
he hasn't been doing it oh and they
don't want him doing interviews and
stuff
it's like it's a little tricky because
he said some crazy [ __ ] you know norm
says crazy [ __ ]
and he said some crazy [ __ ] like like if
you
about someone saying something well you
believe that you'd have to be you'd have
to have down syndrome
huh like you thought that would be
better than saying you'd have to be
[ __ ]
and people like what the [ __ ] damn it
and people got real mad at him i think
it was on the stern show
he's just he's just a treasure that guy
you